-This is very exciting.
Congratulations on another
season of "Search Party."
-Thank you.
-I -- It's such a fun character.
But we should also clarify
because you are also --
As a young person in New York,
this is not you, John.
You are not this person.
-No.
He may look like me.
-[ Laughs ]
-But no, it's not me.
Yeah, it's --
You know, of course, there are
parts of my own personalit
that I, like, exploit and employ
for the role.
-Sure, there's your flair.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, yes.
But no, he is not me.
He's very like --
You know, I lived in Brookly
in my 20s, as well,
but I think I have
just a kind of modicum
of, you know,
appropriate white guilt
kind of coursing through
my system at all times.
And there is none of that
in these characters.
They're like -- They're kind o
like brazen gentrifiers.
-It's really fun
that the show --
-You go.
-No, no, please.
-No, no.
-It just -- The show, it's bee
really fun to watch it develop
And the amount
of plotting behind it
is something that I think mayb
people wouldn't have guessed
from watching the pilot
in this show.
It's a really cool journey
-Totally. Well, it's like --
I feel like it gorgeously
kind of --
If you go back
to the first episode,
we all seem so kind of innocen
and unaware.
And I do feel like
they have no idea
what they're about
to get sucked into.
And I do feel like
there is something --
You know, in the --
In the case of the show,
they don't know that they're
about to get sucked into
this mystery plot,
you know, whatever.
I won't say anything here.
You have to just watch it.
But, like -- But I do feel it is
kind of a gorgeous metapho
for, like, you know, so many
white people in Brooklyn
not sensing the collapse
of the American empire.
-Yeah. I think that's a very -
-Just, like, the amount
of brunches I had in Brooklyn,
just completely clueless
of the impending doom.
-[ Laughs ]
-And it's really fun to watc
that now, retrospectively.
-One of the things that's been
consistent throughout the show
and has been a lot of fun
to watch is incredible costumes.
You wore a see-through shirt
that was wardrobe from the sho
on "Late Night."
Very memorable.
-From Season 3.
-Yeah.
-Wait, what did you say?
-It was very memorable
when you wore it on the show
-Thank you.
-As good a shirt as been wor
on my show, I think.
-Yeah. It's in the Smithsonian
-[ Laughs ]
What does it feel like
when you get to see those
for the first time
before you put them on?
-It's so confusing to me.
They're such --
It's like the more expensive
they get --
I mean, literally everything
I wear on that show is --
I'm not kidding, the average
price is like $2,000.
Like, individual pieces.
You know?
And it's like
the more expensive they get,
the more just, like, deepl
unrecognizable they get to me.
I don't --
I can't locate them in culture
I'm putting them on my legs,
and he's like, "That's a shirt."
The costume designer, Matthe
Simonelli, who's a genius,
he's always like, "What do you
think? What do you think?"
And I'm like,
"This is not a criticism.
I just literally
don't know what I think.
I don't know."
But yeah, it's like,
we talked a lot
about Edina from "Absolutely
Fabulous," Jennifer Saunders
-Yes.
-Just, like, the layering of -
Just, like, the haphazard
layering of expensive item
with no kind of --
He clearly doesn't --
What I love about the costum
is, like, he doesn't look good
-Right.
-And he doesn't know
if he looks bad or good.
It's just important to him
to have as many obvious
signifiers of wealth on hi
at all times, at the expense
of the silhouette.
-The absence of both taste
and awareness
is a very dangerous cocktail
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
It's my favorite kind of,
you know, character to play.
-Well, you're great at it.
And I'm so excited
there's another season.
And it's always such a delight
to see you, John,
hopefully next time in person.
-Please. I pray, Seth.
I'm so jealous of the wood beam,
the exposed beam.
-Thank you.
-The fixtures are so iconic.
I just --
I'm so jealous.
I wish I was there with you.
-We would love to --
Some company in the attic
would mean the world
to me, as well.
-"Flowers in the Attic."
-[ Laughs ] Yes,
"Flowers in the Attic."
Thank you, John.
-Bye, Seth!
-Bye.